he is part of the broadcast with Chris
Webber and Marv Albert Game three of
Golden State and New Orleans 8:00 p.m.
Eastern on TNT that comes up on Friday
night he is David Aldridge how you doing
d8 sir I am better for chatting with you
if this is the National if this was the
National Football League David we would
be saying the Rockets are done Rockets
are finished and and that's the usual
week-to-week League that thing it's an
NBA playoff seven-game series how do you
read what Utah was able to pull off in
Houston last night David well I like I
think you saw matches up as well with
Houston as anybody does right I mean if
you look at the Rockets one of the
biggest advantages they have over most
teams is the point capella in the middle
I mean he's just been sensational all
season he is great in the screen and
role at both ends whether it's
offensively or defensively his rim
wounds get spaced the floor his presence
spaces the floor and I think having a
guy like Gobert in the middle takes
something not all but takes a lot of
that away and a lot of that advantage
away for Houston at both ends of the
floor again I mean you know Gobert
obviously as an outstanding defensive
player the numbers the Rockets have with
him on the floor defensively this season
are insane so that's one thing and then
you add the ability to make shots which
Utah has you start with ingles but now
you have Mitchell in there also who can
make shots and I always thought Jae
Crowder in big games was a very very
good shot maker right I mean he seems to
rise to the occasion do they have that
now not having not having Rubio is a
problem and will be a problem for Utah
at least last night I thought Exim
played pretty well and get a good job
that that will be a problem as the
series goes on though longer the rupiahs
out so now that home court goes to Utah
now James Harden the beard has to face
Mitt Romney and the rest of that crew
there how do you see Houston digging
deep here David now that they are
standing and also look Chris Paul has
I'm sure he's sick of hearing it never
made it to a Conference Finals never and
now he needs to come up with one win in
Utah to try and have a chance to do that
with Houston right I don't think it you
know look I think just is a better team
I think Houston will win the series I
don't think it's certainly don't think
it's outside of their their talent level
to win a game in Utah JH difficult
because you chose real good at home but
not impossible but yeah look Utah's
playing with a lot of confidence as they
should they're playing with house money
nobody expects them to be Houston so
they can play free and and kind of loose
and easy so from that standpoint I I
think it will be as I said difficult but
not impossible for Houston to win a game
on the road and take it right back and
finish the series in six maybe seven
games but yeah I mean I think that
they're they'll be fine they've been if
not the best defensive team to leave one
of the two or three best defensive teams
in the league all season as long as they
come back to that as they get if they
get back to that I think they'll be fine
it did not play with a whole lot of
energy either n last night and it cost
so before we turn the page to the rest
of the playoffs and including the series
you doing with Marvin C Webb mountains
moved to New Orleans you've seen you've
seen so much basketball da in your time
with ESPN Washington Post and more can
you place in perspective what we're
seeing out of Donovan Mitchell right now
it's so it's special it is you know as
good a big game rookie performances as
I've seen in some time you know you go
back to magic and and those guys who
played at that level when they were
rookies Michael did it his second year
with the 63 and he's 63 against the
Celtics
so you certainly seen it from
the greatest players it's it's unusual
just because no the pedigree of Donovan
Mitchell did not suggest that this is
what he was going to be capable of you
know in all fairness to him and I mean
just all due respect to him that was not
what the thought process on was on him
coming out of Louisville last year I
mean you know most NBA scouts that I
talked to thought hey this you know he
has to be a good player it seems to be
maybe a real good player but I don't
think anybody saw this and it changes
the trajectory of a franchise when you
get a player with this kind of impact
where you where the Jazz drafted him so
it just makes every you know it gives
them possibilities that they may not
have thought of before
he has been spectacular he is not
shirking from the moment he is embracing
the moment and still playing at the
level that he's been at all year it's
it's very unusual and tribute to the kid
he's been awesome and you've covered a
series where Anthony Davis prior to you
know running into the Golden State
buzzsaw was just bursting just an
absolute burst on the scene with what
happened with Portland give me the
recipe for Alvin Gentry and this team to
have a shot is there what you cut one
for me David against Golden State tough
for them it's tough for Mitch cos I
thought they actually played pretty well
in Game two I mean they kept coming back
and coming back and you know they they
fell down and came back and they
challenged Golden State throughout that
game up until the very end of the game
um but it they just it's just so hard to
stop the Warriors who are doing what
they want to do it's just so difficult
because especially now with curry back
it they just have an ability to make
shots you know on a given night one of
those three may be off and even the
other night I don't think Durant played
all that well for three quarters and
klay didn't play well at all and it
still didn't matter because curry was
back and was on fire so it that the the
idea that all three of those guys are
going to be off is just you just can't
put odds on that if you're the
opposition and that's what makes them so
difficult to stop because one of those
guys is probably get 30 you
I mean that just makes it so much easier
for the rest of them but I will say this
I thought the pelicans brought a lot
more fight to Game two they were a lot
more aggressive that's not the word I'm
looking for defensively they're a lot
more efficient defensively I thought
they did a much better job of taking
away some of Golden State's space that
they like to operate in you know the
first game they got cut up by the by the
split action that the Warriors love to
run it's just so difficult to practice
that because you just don't know you
can't do it in in real time and practice
I think maybe if I'm New Orleans I'm
hanging my hat on maybe my guys are
figuring out the split action a little
bit better
we're Durant and Thompson or you know
creating havoc off the dribble and maybe
if we can keep them from both having big
nights we can stay in a game and we can
get to the line a little bit more at
home because I know that the pelicans
feel like they should have gotten more
calls in Games one and two they will get
more free-throws slow the game down
allow our defense to set up I mean there
is a formula it's not I'm not going to
lie to you I don't know that it's much
of one but there is one where you can
you can beat Golden State especially
when you're at home and they're on the
road David Aldridge was definitely not a
fill-in guest as he opined he would
we've talked NBA and I wanted David
Aldridge so I'm like let's get David
Aldridge that is the truth that is the
truth what do you think happens tonight
we won't talk about house money
Cleveland has that in in front of them
this evening in Toronto and then Boston
Terry Rozier what a story
taking on Philadelphia what do you see
tonight in that double dip David I think
really I think Phil he's gonna play a
lot better I mean you know they had have
been off for a week and they showed it
looked like they were off for a week and
you know they didn't bring the juice as
Gregg Popovich likes to say they just
didn't have the energy in Boston had all
the energy I think Philly will bring a
lot more energy tonight what Boston does
what Brad Stevens does is just
incredible what
the the way he gets maxes out whatever
group of players he has available to him
on a given night is just amazing the
confidence that they all play with is a
tribute to him and that staff because
you know most guys who don't get a lot
of run when you're thrown in they get
you're in the headlights look they got
nerves these guys all feel like no we
can play and it's because Stevens gives
them that confidence that they can go do
things but I think feeling I think Billy
wins tonight I just have a feeling
Philly's gonna play a lot better I think
indeed will play a lot better I think
all their guys will play a lot better
and no even that series up you know what
Toronto and Cleveland I don't know man
I'll put it in Toronto doesn't beat them
this year I don't know that they're ever
do you have every advantage you could
possibly ask for to play against LeBron
James his team's not that good your team
is deep and has has been the best team
in the East all year all year most of
the second half of the season you got
home quarter you had home court
advantage you know there's no excuse
there's no excuse for not beating this
team and they and they somehow managed
to get Game one I don't know how they
did it but they did it so now you got
some work to do because now you got
LeBron thinking he might be able to
steal this thing and that that's a bad
bad recipe for the Raptors and I'm gonna
go with our sports talk radio question
for you to wrap up our conversation my
god Chris Brockman had this idea for a
poll question that we we decided to go
against yesterday if you had a choice of
somebody for the next five years Chris
asked him that question yeah for the
next five years da would you rather have
LeBron James on your team or Brad
Stevens coaching your team you have a
choice of one well for the next five
years what works for where they are
right now
you'd rather have Brad Stevens because
LeBron is 33 I mean if it's it was 23 Oh
LeBron well the reason why we asked is
because of how LeBron is playing
I mean he's playing his best great he's
best basketball you could say I was
entire right here no questions but you
know look I'll just say this father time
continues as far as I know is still
undefeated this level I will take
Stevens just because he seems to have
such an incredible
ability to as I say get the most out of
whoever he's coaching it's just
remarkable
and no being obviously no disrespect to
LeBron but he's 33 I mean at some point
you start to show your age even in even
him so yeah I'll go with Stevens because
then I've got you know more trips to
Boston which is David always enjoy your
your presence on TV whenever a Suzy and
I see you or there's David and and
always enjoy our chats on the show yes
Richard can I can just one thing yes I
just want to be fair to our former
employer at the world know I know
they've got they've got the game I know
I'm here they will be doing three or
four and then if there's a game five
then you will see Marvin C webinar okay
but see you are you are fair and
balanced David thank you pretty Michael
thank you
that's David Aldridge Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience